- Now I always like to close
out with something trending
I don't want you to miss,
this is what I'm liking
I do really enjoy baking,
but it can be hard.
Even harder, making a dessert
look like a masterpiece.
I've never done that. We
can see some of the best
of the best try their hand
at creating edible art
in a super fun new baking
series on Prime Video.
It's called 'Dr. Seuss Baking Challenge.'
(upbeat trumpet music)
- I'm Tamera Mowry-Housley, welcome to
the city of Seuss.
I would like to invite you
with the wave of my hand,
to a new competition
set in a magical land.
We've gathered some bakers
the finest we know, Dr.
Seuss Baking Challenge
is the name of the show.
Nine teams will create
these characters so sweet,
will their dreams soar
high, or collapse in
defeat? (upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
- That looks so crazy
cool! We have the host of
the show on the line right
now, she's an actress,
producer, entrepreneur, and author
she does all the things y'all.
Let's say hi to Tamera
Mowry-Housley what's up!?
- Hi Kelly. You look beautiful!
- Oh thank you, I love
Christmas time! You look
beautiful as well I
love that lip girl. So,
this show looks so much
fun, but looking at your
new show I'm assuming
you're a big Dr. Seuss
fan am I correct?
- Oh my gosh absolutely, I mean who isn't?
I can remember being
introduced to Dr. Seuss in
kindergarten, I was reading
green eggs and ham and
I can remember my
kindergarten teacher, she
actually made green eggs
and ever since then I've
just been a fan and now
I'm reading the same books
to my kids. So, it's
amazing to see how these
cake artists, these pastry
chefs, make you know
these amazing bakeries
look like something that
just come out of a Dr.
Seuss book because the
thing about Dr. Seuss is
a lot of the animation
looks like it's moving
and the fact that they did
this with like cake, it's
so mind blowing and so
much fun to watch but also to taste.
It was amazing.
- They seem so gifted
they bring it to life
you know they bring it
like right off the pages
it's such a talent.
Everybody you can catch Tameras' new show
'Dr, Seuss Baking Challenge'
Streaming on Prime Video
beginning today so go
do it. You can also find
her new book 'You should
sit down for this'
which is a great title.
It's a memoir about
life, wine, and cookies,
it's in stores now y'all.
Thank you so much Tamera
I'm liking your post!
(audience cheers)
I'm still loving you!
- I love you!
- All right bye girl.
Okay so we've hit the time
when we usually give our
guests $1,000, courtesy
of our seasonal partner
Pilot Pen, makers of
friction our go to
erasable pens of the Kelly
Clarkson Show, but today
I'm thinking she's all right
she don't need any money
so I'm gonna give it to
someone in the audience
so look under your seats.
You might have a check for
$1,000 taped to your seat.
(soft music and drum roll)
who's got it who's got it?
(screaming)
- Oh!
- Oh my god I love your
response! What's your name?
- Dashani!
- Dashani, first of all yes
with your hair it's beautiful,
secondly what do you think
you'll do with the money?
- Um I don't know buy
stuff for my dogs cuz' I
love them and they deserve it!?
(laughing) (clapping)
- I love that response.
Jesse and I, we all
dogs, we love our dogs
they're like our children
as well so enjoy I hope your dog gets
some great toys.
- Thank you so much.
- Well thank you so much to all our
guests today, Amy
Poehler, Gabriel Labelle,
Aurora James,
our in house grumpy elf and
Samara Joy. Y'all have
a great day, and if it's
not try and change it.